Yakuza like a dragon the next entry and
a long-running franchise that is near
and dear to my heart and here to talk
about it with me is scotch trigger the
localization producer for Yahoo's will
like a dragon how you doing Scott good
man how are you I'm hanging in there
so I have a ton of questions about this
so I'm gonna I'm gonna grill you on all
of them because I want to know
everything about y'all cause I like a
dragon I have been keeping up with the
Japanese release but you know of course
with the localization comes a lot of
different nuances to the Western release
but for those who are either not
familiar or haven't been keeping up with
the Japanese release can you give us a
rundown of yahooza like a dragon so
bright so on yahooza 6 the song of life
was the end of the arc of cosmic uu our
previous protagonist and so with naka
saw like a dragon we're starting a brand
new story with our brand new protagonist
Ichiban kasuga we've completely revamped
the combat system and so you get more of
a JRPG system it's a turn-based battle
system now so we're set in yokohama
primarily versus comércio so there's a
whole bunch of new stuff happening as we
kind of launch into this new a new turn
for the series it's everything it is
everything about its Creed pre-new now
one of the things about the Yaak is a
franchise was people always ask where do
I start
it's it's such a such a deep history and
obviously now the whole franchise is on
ps4 but is this a good place to you for
people to start getting into Yakuza
absolutely it's a it's the beginning of
a brand new story for each bond it's
there's there's obviously some stuff
that connects to the previous games
because you know it's it's one
continuous story but we're not in a
position where we're still gonna be
saying hey man you need to pay a
clay-like 200 hours of previous gameplay
to understand this one interaction kind
of thing you know so that's very much
symbolized by our kind of name change
with from the Japanese version to Yahoo
so like a dragon we feel it's a hugely
perfect spot for jumping into the series
if you've never played it before so a
lot of us have a very strong attachment
to cosmic you but like like yeah and
like you've said we've kind of closed
the book on his story but what can you
tell us about costigan Ichiban he's
almost the polar opposite is that fair
to say that's really fair to say yeah he
you know cosmic you you where it's
keeps his emotions in check you know
it's very stoic he he has that same like
they both share like a kind of curiosity
about the world that's what gets them
involved in all the hydrants that get
into you right but Ichiban wears his
emotions on its sleeve he says we thinks
he he's very charismatic he's outgoing
there's there's there is a kind of a
polar opposite kind of shift that's
happening for Ichiban from as you
compare him to cure you now when you're
trying to kind of characterize him
through localization
there's obviously that that's the bulk
of the work that you and your team have
to do but what can you tell us about
what it's like to kind of localize his
personality for the Western release like
what are some of the nuances that you do
where did some of the characterizations
that you make specifically for him to
kind of get that personality across
right so Ichiban has compared compared
to Curia at least he's he's more of a I
guess you could seize a little more
Street he grew up on the on the fringes
of society much like here you but also
in in kind of he was born in a soap land
he was born in and raised in in
shangri-la the famous soap line that's
been with the series forever and as a
result he's a little bit more casual
speaking he he I wouldn't say he dips
into like that what we characterize as
like the Kansai accent but there's
definitely a little bit more of like the
fast-talking easygoing kind of nature
about his speech patterns that were
present in previous protagonists we're
Tamil localization but to pivot back for
just a minute like for those who may not
understand what localization is how
would you explain it to them as the
difference between translation and
localization translation would be
something that is as as true to the
written word as could possibly be be had
and uh you know we get really into like
translation philosophy you know you can
you can basically translate the same
sentence and maybe from any source
language to a target language six
different ways and it would all be
accurate for a localization I think the
requirement is simply that the
experience be carried over from in our
case the Japanese users experience to a
West changes experience we're trying to
mirror the same amount of humor and
drama that you would have experienced
had you been able to play and understand
the game in Japanese and that's where
and takes a translation to the next
level because we're conveying and
experience more so than just words a lot
of that shows through in sort of the the
humor I guess I know that the yahoos of
franchise is of course very well known
for its how it uses humor to kind of
build its world and its characters but
with the Auggie's of like a dragon what
can you tell me about the level of
absurdity that you're leaning into
because from the gameplay that we've
seen that some folks are looking at
right now this game ratchets up the
absurdity quite a bit and that's saying
a lot
that's saying a lot so what's it like to
work with that kind of level of the
level of humor and absurdity I think you
know from from to answer your first
question I mean from a like how much
humour an absurdity is in the game you
know obviously we our main story is
still very dramatic and like heavy at
times and criminal underworld like all
that stuff happening but the you know
when you look at like where the Yaak is
a series kind of lives right where you
on one side of that like ultimate kind
of craziness you've got your quizzes
euro and then on the other kind of more
serious more more introspective type
you've got more like dr. Seuss this one
definitely skews more toward that yok is
a zero level of like singing and crazy
and personally I love that about it I
love working on the humorous type stuff
just because I think I don't know it's
just a personal philosophy that video
games can and should be funny like this
just like you don't want to sit down and
get like bummer town right like a lot of
things about games that just are lend
themselves to humor and being able to
work in the world that is so humorous
and really kind of twist on a dime you
know like that's that's one of my
favorite things about the series yeah
yeah it's it feels very natural to at
least from my experience with the yahoos
of franchise and also one of my other
favorite features of the franchise are
sub stories can you tell me a little bit
about like sort of sub stories that
we're gonna get involved with here and
tell me about your favorite Stubbs sub
story that you've seen so far oh my you
got you got to tell me man right so
there's like there's another 50 of them
they're basically all set in Yokohama
this time I think the sub stories are
definitely aware that the level gets
amped you know on the crazy there's
still of course like the heartwarming
sub stories there's a lot of things that
really like set Ichiban apart you know
Andrea you learn a bit about his history
through them but a lot of them are just
nuts like there's one where he is this
sickly girl is looking at a persimmon
tree and says you know she says win this
persimmon falls from the tree I think
that's gonna be my last day on this
earth and he's like never and so he goes
through like this multiple stages of
protecting this persimmon tree from like
various he protects it from a sumo
wrestler who's using it for practice and
then this snipers like shooting at the
persimmon for practice and he's just
like he's going to all-all-all ends to
make sure this person never falls from
the tree and it's really cute and fun
and that's just one that came to top my
head oh yeah I don't doubt it man it's
definitely one of the one of the
highlights of the series I think it's
it's an opportunity for the characters
is kind of its kind of show who they are
and it helps like make the world feel
like it's lived in and I think going off
of that too is that over time we've seen
the franchise be more and more
representative of different groups of
people particularly like LGBTQ LGBTQ
representation what can you tell me
about that with like a dragon if if it
goes to those lengths to kind of like
push the envelope in terms of
representation I mean it's still set in
Asia it's still set in a world where you
know we don't and we don't take that out
of that for sure you know it's in set in
Japan and it deals with people who live
on the margins of that society you know
and this time we are dealing with a
three fraction kind of war between
Japanese Korean Chinese and that's
that's another aspect of I guess
representation is Asian representation
just to make sure Tourette's and you
know cuz I think that that's that's also
important I can't think of any specific
other like ways that this is like
pushing the envelope but you will
definitely be talking a lot about like I
said people who live on the margins and
that's you know Ichiban from from his so
planned born kind of things and a lot of
things have to do with the circumstances
of his birth they deal heavily with the
politics of
brothels and prostitution and what
that's like for those those women living
and working in that world and you know
this those are things that our story and
the franchise in general continues to
explore in ways that are both realistic
and also kind of hopefully pushing
forward that envelope a little bit to
explore those things now when you go
from like komuro Joe is almost its own
character that you know when you jump
into the game you get an immediate sense
of where you are because it's modeled so
heavily after kabukicho red-light
district and it's just neon lights and
so many things happening on the street
how are you characterizing or how hard
is it to pivot to Yokohama and trying to
characterize that place as opposed to
Camaro Joe it's it's crazy because
Yokohama is like three times the size of
Camacho in the game and it's split into
what I think it's seven districts of
like you know you've got like uptown low
town to town to Chinatown and like Tom
Akita Park is in there like all these
foot real places of course I've mixed in
and you really get a vibe for each
little community inside of that area
that as you're kind of traveling you can
see the architecture change you can see
the NPC's change you can see it's so
much about you know just crossing the
street makes you feel like you're almost
kind of traveling to another section of
a town and I think that comes across
really really well and it you know it
doesn't throw you at the whole whole map
and say go you know it definitely gives
it a little bit and yeah it makes you
kind of learn each little each little
pub before you kind of move to the next
and under and then you really get this
overarching picture there's just this
incredible diversity that's in Oklahoma
I'm assuming that's Yokohama is gonna be
filled with tons of minigames too
what can you tell me about many games
and as a second question to follow up to
that are we gonna have karaoke yes
there's karaoke there's not karaoke it's
each each character has their own song
because it's a party based game this
time so super fun
you're gonna look forward to that but
minigames are at this time as if they
weren't already I know we've got dragon
Kart which is full
on like the streets of Tokyo racing
pretty neat game you know you can shoot
rocket launchers and hit power boosts
and all that kind of stuff very popular
game I'm sure you know and then there's
this other committee game one of my
favorites is that Ichiban goes into a
classic movie theater which is just so
comfortable that he starts falling
asleep and you have to like it's almost
like a rhythm game you have to punch
away the rim Rams to like make him stop
falling asleep if they're like casting
their magic spells on the ended like
acid make it fall asleep it's hilarious
and awesome
man so one thing that I think the
localization team talks about a lot is
or at least the thing that stands out to
me when the localization team talks
about what they do is kind of Jay pcs
and just how heavy it is to just go
through a huge script and localize that
translate and localize and edit that and
also making UI elements work when they
get translated or localized so one how
many Jay pcs are there and I could
dragon can you explain what that is and
and also are there any particular
challenges when it comes to making
because this is an RPG for the record
this game this game was not supposed to
escopeta
when we initially talked started talking
about it like last year I've been
working on this game for over a year at
this point for a lot less JP seas than
the game into that beam a jpc is a
Japanese character a single blow G a
single word that can often account for a
single character that can often account
for an entire English word right so or
you know one or two generally equals an
English word that's the this game ended
up being closer to 1.2 1.3 million jpc
which is about the size of Yahoo's zero
and that's wild the office of five
remains like the biggest and the most
mysterious game that we never have to
encounter but this one is a very very
massive game
lots of checks what was the second party
question so uh if there's anything if
there's anything particular about
localizing an RPG as opposed to like are
there UI elements that present different
types of challenges
yeah yeah it's you know there's a lot of
like like
you I that is kind of like you know
attack defend that kind of stuff that
all kind of came to play a lot of it the
heat actions used an entirely new kind
of interface the and then of course
there's this just still tons of graphic
text you know like they all that all the
enemy names that pop off on the screen
and that kind of stuff and we're always
trying to make sure that that's just
playful and as interesting as it can be
there's a lot of like when that when
they when something happens in battle
like it'll be like you know this
character taunts you like that would be
like the general kind of Japanese
translations you know you were taunted
by this guy but we give it that yeah cos
of flavor and it's like starts Mad Dog
and you kind of thing you know it's like
there's a lot of that like taking what
Jacques is about and transferring that
into a JRPG and really merging those
worlds this this is a question for a lot
of folks out there when it comes to
Western versions of Japanese games is
how much freedom do you have when you do
the localization we've had conversations
about this before but for the folks who
may not be familiar with those
conversations can you explain a little
bit about how how much your team has the
freedom to kind of make the game their
own even though this has already been
out in Japan where the team trust us
implicitly and when when something comes
up that we're like ah this this would be
really cool if you could do this it's
automatically like I have weekly calls
with those guys I'm talking them on a
weekly basis and during when we've been
doing that for a year right so like I've
been talking to them about things that
are like well you know this is gonna be
really difficult for us or this is this
will be something that you know I want
you guys to consider when you're making
the game is to make sure that you know
this is something that you've been stand
behind as a localization choice because
you know we're gonna be as accurate and
as true to this as possible so what do
you feel like you know it when we have
to translate it this way how do you how
does that make you feel as to you right
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
back and forth then because not it's not
it's not like a we do our game then you
do our game and I think a lot of you
know the internet idea is that well the
localization team is just out there
ruining it by putting their own spin on
it and it's like no that's not the case
we're literally talking to the team
about that getting sign off on
everything talking them through it and
coming up with a way that makes it work
in the West as well as it did in Japan
too
and convey that experience that a
Japanese player would have had I guess
another thing that people are probably
wondering about or are a little iffy on
is the general direction towards an RPG
because like if you're familiar if folks
are familiar goose has always been this
like 3d kind of brawler type of game but
the transition to RPG I mean we've all
seen the gameplay at this point and kind
of know how that flows almost like a
dragon quest as Casa Gabon is a big fan
of himself in lore but what would you
what would you say to those who are kind
of on the fence about this new approach
I think the team has really done an
incredible job of making sure that the
game the JRPG gameplay is just as snappy
and cool-looking
as though it were an action game they
really transferred the experience of
that action game and distilled it down
to a Garrett a turn-based RPG which
makes it I guess a little more
accessible like there's a lot of people
I think in the passive like that's an
action game I can I can mash the buttons
if the do things right and that this not
only does that open then us up to a new
audience but I think the fans who you're
talking about you know I understand the
skepticism not you know when we're
talking about the change I think that
it's both like something that was on the
you know when we did the April Fool's
joke right you actually did it but the
the you know the interest level has been
high I think it's you definitely have to
give it a shot there's a lot of ways
that we've maintained an action-oriented
system and this JRPG think it's so
snappy it's so it's so fun and
interesting and even if you're not like
the biggest JRPG fan if you're still a
jock as a fan it's still gonna have a
lot of yeah I know going back to the
April Fool's joke everyone I was I was
like I'm a huge persona fan so I'm like
you know what if what if I can have a
yahooza game that plays like persona and
I'll say oh they wait they would never
do that I think I think they got it made
with with the Yakuza forum yeah it was
like it's gonna be it's gonna be a mini
game we're like nah that's the whole
game guys that's really exciting man I
know a few folks who have already been
playing the Japanese version but I'm
holding out until it comes out and what
what can you tell us about release date
so far we're day in date with the Xbox
series X hardware whenever they decide
to announce that day will be there on
Xbox series X PlayStation 4 steam
Windows 10 and PlayStation 4 of course
cool appreciate the work that work that
you do and appreciate you taking the
time to talk to us about what lesser man
yeah hey Scott take care man you too
so that's y'all kazoo like a drag game
it's coming out later this year so keep
your eyes peeled for that because Casa
de ichiban has a story to tell us and
stick with us here at GameSpot because
we have so many more developer
interviews and exclusive gameplay for
play for all and don't forget to donate
to the causes that we are supporting
links are in this description below and
see you next time
[Music]